[Música]
después de ser testigo de la ira
violenta de los bebés cuando se les
priva de un elemento que consideran suyo
Jean pi uno de los fundadores de la
psicología infantil observó algo
profundo sobre la naturaleza humana
nuestro sentido de propiedad surge muy
temprano por qué somos tan posesivos hay
un feno en psicología conocido como el
efecto de Posesión por el que valoramos
mucho más altamente las cosas Tan pronto
como las poseemos en una demostración a
unos estudiantes se les dio a elegir
entre una taza de café y una barra de
chocolate suizo como recompensa por su
ayuda con la investigación una mitad
eligió la taza y la otra el chocolate es
decir parecían valorar las recompensas
de manera similar a otros estudiantes se
les dio primero una taza y luego una
posibilidad sorpresiva de cambiarla por
una barra de chocolate pero solo el 11
por quiso sin embargo otro grupo comenzó
con el chocolate y la mayoría
prefirieron quedárselo En otras palabras
los estudiantes casi siempre dan mayor
valor a la recompensa inicial en parte
tiene que ver con la rapidez con que
hacemos conexiones entre nuestro sentido
de nosotros mismos y las cosas que
consideramos nuestras eso Incluso se
puede ver a nivel neuronal en un
experimento científicos escanearon los
cerebros de los participantes mientras
asignaban diferentes objetos a una cesta
etiquetada mía o a otra etiquetada de
Alex cuando los participantes miraron
sus objetos nuevos sus cerebros
mostraron mayor actividad en una región
que por lo general destella cada vez que
pensamos en nosotros mismos otra razón
del apego a nuestras posesiones Es que
desde temprana edad creemos que tienen
una esencia única los psicólogos nos lo
muestran al convencer mediante la
ilusión a niños de 3 a 6 años que
construyeron una máquina de copiar capaz
de crear réplicas perfectas de cualquier
artículo cuando se les ofreció elegir
entre su juguete favorito o una copia
Aparentemente exacta la mayoría de los
niños prefirió el original de hecho a
menudo se horrorizaron ante la
posibilidad de llevarse una copia este
pensamiento mágico acerca de los objetos
no es algo que se vaya al crecer más
bien persiste en la edad adulta aunque
se hace cada vez más elaborado por
ejemplo consideremos el valor que se da
a artículos que han pertenecido a
celebridades es como si los compradores
creyeran que los objetos han sido de
alguna forma imbuidos en la esencia de
sus antiguos
dueños similarmente somos reacios a
desprendernos de herencias que nos
ayudan a sentirnos conectados con
nuestros seres queridos estas creencias
pueden llegar a alterar nuestra
percepción del mundo físico y cambiar
nuestras capacidades atléticas a los
participantes de un estudio se les dijo
que estaban usando un palo de golf
propiedad del excampeón Ben Curtis
durante el experimento percibían el hoyo
como si fuera un centímetro más grande
que el de los participantes de control
que usaban un Potter estándar y lograron
más
pots aunque los sentimientos de
propiedad surgen temprano en la vida la
cultura también cumple un papel por
ejemplo se descubrió que los hadsa del
norte de tanzania que están aislados de
la modernidad no muestran el efecto de
Posesión esto puede deberse a que viven
en una sociedad igualitaria donde todo
se comparte en el otro extremo a veces
nuestro apego a nuestras cosas puede ir
demasiado lejos parte de la causa del
trastorno de acumulación es un alto
sentido de responsabilidad y protección
hacia las pertenencias
es por eso que a las personas con esta
condición les resulta tan difícil tirar
algo lo que falta saber es cómo va a
cambiar la relación con nuestras
posesiones con la aparición de las
tecnologías
digitales muchos pronostican la
desaparición de los libros y la música
Física Pero por ahora al menos esto
parece prematuro tal vez siempre habrá
algo satisfactoriamente único sobre
tener un objeto en nuestras manos y
decir que es
nuestro listo para seguir aprendiendo
mira estos videos para desafiar lo que
crees que sabes o para aprender más
sobre lo que no suscríbete y mantén la
[Música]
curiosidad